السلام
عليكم اي حد فيكم بيقضي ليله راس السنه
ازاي اكيد خارج مع اصحابه او بيتفسح او
على الاقل مس انا قضتها بعيط
مقهوره بفكر من وانا صغيره وانا بنت تخينه
كنت دايما الاقي المدرسين يرجعوني في اخر
ديسك ورا بحجه المصده الحل مع ان نظري كان
ضعيف
كنت بتحرم من المشاركه في عروض الرقص مع
اني كنت بحبه جدا وبقعد اقله حركات البنات
واعمل زيهم بس ما كانوش بيض يدخلوني عشان
انا بنت تخينه ولما قررت اشترك في نشاط
طلابي نقلوني من اللجنه الفنيه للجنه
الاجتماعيه عشان انا لت تخينه ومش هعرف
اشارك في حفلاات المدرس ولما كبرت شويه
بدات معانتي مع اللبس بقيت اضطر اشتري لبس
اكبر من ساني ولما كبرت اكتر بقيت اضطر
اشتري اي حاجه لمجرد انها على المقاس عشان
تعبت من اللف ولما كبت شويه كمان بقيت
ادخل المحل ومن البا يبقى لي مافيش مقاس
وفي مره كنت داخله محل لقيت البنت اللي
هناك بتقوللي على فكره انت ممكن تلاقي
مقاسك محل الحوامل اللي جنبنا ميرسي ربنا
يخليكي مره بقى كان عندي مناسبه مهمه جدا
وداخله اشتري
الفستان مع اول فستان مسكته لقيت الموظفه
اللي في المحل ققول لي لا مش هيخش
فيكي هو اصلا ما كانش عاجبني قلت لها طبعا
هقيس قالت لي لا مش هت قيسيه لو قسيه
هيتقطع قلت لها يس وما يتقطع هطك فلوس
ادات جدا من الاخه وطلبت المدير جالي
المدير واعتذر وقاللي اتفضلي اس دخلت
البروفا رميت الفستان وفضلت
اعي حتى الشغل او العمل التطوعي اللي انت
مشترك فيه تلاقي الترقيات تعينات بالتخن
والف بغض النظر عن الكفاءه المهم انك شكلك
حلو ووجهه لطيفه في مره كنت رايحه من
الانترفيو لقيت الاتش ار بتقول لي لا احنا
مش هينفع نقبلك اصل انت محتاجه تخسي يعني
اترفضت عشان انا بنت تخينه مش عشان انا مش
كف لا سمح
الله وفي البيت بقى بلاقي اخواتي دايما
اول ما يشوفوا حد تخين في التلفزيون يقولي
الح س تعالي تعالي دي
شبهي ح خلي ولا مثلا لما نيجي نتغدى قيهم
يوسعون لي مكان كبير قوي قي عشان طك يعني
بيحبوني ولا ماما تيجي في قعدتها مع
العيله ومع اصحابها يها بتقول اه والله
سلمه تخنت قوي بقول لها كتير تخس بس هي مش
عايزه رغم ان سلمى دي حاولت تخس كتير جدا
عملت كل حاجه عشان تخس حرمت نفسها من
الاكل سنين
وشهور وفكرت تعمل كل حاجه دايت ورياضه
ورياضه ودايت لحد ما كرهتهم وكرهت سيرتهم
بس انا كنت بعجر ماما لما كانت بتعمل كده
انا نفسي كنت بععد اعش على نفسي مع اصحابي
بفضل ان انا اجرح نفسي بنفسي ولا حد فيهم
يجرحني طول الوقت اقول اوع الفراشه اوع
الصاروخ عشان محدش
يضايقني نيجي بقى للناس اللي بتتعامل
معايا قيهم دايما ينادولي الاسماء من عيال
يا دبدوبه يا بكبوزه يا قربوه بس صدقوني
ده كان ارحم بكتير من ان حد يقوللي يا
مي بضع
العر مره كان في عريس م خ م ص عشان بس اه
ما يزعلوش لقيته بقولي هو انت مش بتفكري
تخسي رغم ان هو نفسه كان بكرش واقرا بشكل
وحش ده غير السطحيه
والتفه بس مارح محتاج يهم لكن هو اختز
وبدا لما شفت البوست اللي على الفيسبوك
اللي كانت بنت كاتباه بتقول فيه ان البنت
التخينه شبه التر وافتكرت الكومنت اللي
كان ولد كاتبه على فيديو لبنت تخينه بيقول
فيه هو بيظهر امتى وعليه جي 500 لايك من
كت ما الناس معجبه بجمال الكومنت بتاعه
يعني
ودايت لما كنت ماشيه في الشارع ليله راس
الس واقفه في اشاره زي خلق الله
حد معدي بيقوللي
يا انا خضيت
جدا
صدمت صحيح رديت عليه وهزقته بس ده لان
مفيش اي حد من واقفين قالله عتش ما يصحش
وافتكرت ان حتى التحرش اللي هو اكر حاجه
البنت بتتعرضلها بقى بالفاظ عنصريه تجاه
البنت التخين من عينت يا عجله يا بغله يا
وحش
روحت بيتنا مقهوره منهاره بعيط كارهه نفسي
وكاره الناس قلت انا لازم احط حد للمدا دي
بدات افكر في عمليات
التخسيس وفعلا وصلت على النت دكتور اسمه
اسامه عمللي العمليه بس قبل ما ارحله رحت
الدكتور نفسه حكيتله اللي حصل وبلغته
بقرار استغرب جدا وسالني ايه اللي وصلك
للمرحله دي قلتله يا
الهر يعمل اكتر من كده افتكرت ان كنت
واثقه في نفسي وان المجتمع ده قدر يهزني
بسهوله رحت لدكتور اسامه وحدد لي عمليه
اسمها تحويل مسار معده العمليه دي عباره
عن ان بيتعمل جيب صغير في المعده وبيتو
بيه الامعاء فبالتالي اي اكل بيتاكل بينزل
من الجيب على الامعاء على طول كنت عارفه
ان العمليه صعبه واني هفضل ثلاث سنين
عايشه على الادويه فيتامينات وحديد
وكالسيوم ممكن تول حياتي كنت عارفه انها
من اخطر عمليات الجهاز
الضب كنت عارفه كمان ان انا هتعب لو اكلت
اي حاجه غريبه على ب كنت عارفه ان في ناس
ماتت وتشوهت وهي بتعمل العمليه بس صممت
وعملتها يوم 111 2015 خسيت 25 كيلو ولسه
فاضل لي 25 كيلو عايزه اقول لكم اني كنت
داخله العمليه مبسوطه جدا ومشجعه وبتصور
سلف بفس العمليات وبهزر مع الدكاتره وانا
اللي بطمن
ومن وقتها ونظرتي اتغيرت لي الحياه بقيت
اخد كل حاجه بايجابيه اي حد يقول لي يا
اخينا قول له مش في ربنا يخليك بس ان
نظرتي ما اتغيرتش بيهم ههم الناس اللي
اهانوني واتريقوا عليا قبل العمليه بس
دلوقتي بقيت بالنسبه لهم تحكه بسكر ما هي
هتخس تخيلوا ان وصلت له بعد العمليه ان كل
البنات بتتعرض لنوع من انواع القهر مش بس
التخينه رفيعه والطويله والسمرا
والقصيره المجتمع هو اللي عنده خلق ويختزل
الناس في
اشكالها كل واحد كان بيترق عليا او عليك
او عليها عشان هو عنده نقص جواه المشاكل
اللي بيتعرض لها تكبر جواه عقده النقص دي
تخليه يدور على الكائن الاضعف يفضل يشاور
على العيوب ويتك عليها وغالبا بتكون البنت
هي الكائن ده المجتمع هو اللي لازم يتغير
انتم اللي لازم تتغيروا لان الطويله مش
هتاثر نفسها والسمرا مش هتروح تاخد حق
تفتيح وتفتح بشرتها ومش كل تخينه تقدر
تعمل عمليه ده غير انكم ما فكرتو ان
البنات دي ممكن تبقى حابه نفسها كده بس
حكمكم على شكلهم وبس هو اللي وصلهم لدرجه
انهم يكرهوا نفسهم انا عن نفسي عملت
العمليه مش عشان عايزه اخس عشان اخلص من
سخافات الناس هم وصلوني لمرحله ان ما بقتش
قادره اعيش حياتي مش عارفه استمتع بحياتي
انا عارفه ان المجتمع صنع جاد لكل حاجات
الر بس اذا كان تخاذلنا وتسامح هيخلينا
فرصه سهله للفر فصعب من ده ان احنا كبنات
نصنع حاله الاستبداد دي بنفسنا المفروض ان
البنت مش كائن ضعيف ولا حد مجبور على امره
ماينفعش ندخل في عز عن كل اللي حواليه لو
في عزله وهجره لازم نعمهم هتبقى هجره
لنفسنا
لاحلامنا
لازم نوسع مداركنا ونجهز نفسنا بكل وسيله
تقدر تساعدنا الجامعه مش المكان اللي
هنتجوز منه الجامعه المكان اللي هنستغنى
في اولى جامعه اشتغلت صحفيه في مواقع جراي
كتير اشتغلت مذيعه راديو دخلت انتخابات
اتحد طلبه وكسبت كنت رئيسه اسره طلابيه في
الجامع كنت عضوه في لجنه ال 50 الطلابيه
لكتابه الدستور عملت حاجات كتير اسست
مبادرات وحملات توعويه حقوقيه كتير في
الشيه ودلوقتي مديره علاقات عامه ما ختش
المدقات اللي بتعرض لها توقفني عن تحقيق
طموحي رغم
قساوتها حتى البنت اللي ما كانش ليه حظ في
التعليم تقدر جنب من وهي في بيتها تمتهن
المهنه صغيره تجنبها تحكمات المفع
وضوه ما ينفعش نقعد في بيوتنا ونقول احنا
ممين لا لازم نشتغل على نفسنا لازم نكتشف
مهاراتنا ونطورها لازم نقرا ونت
لازم نعمل حاجات كتير ونسبه وجنا في
المجتمع
ده
اخيرا يمكن تكون الاسباب اللي دفعتني
العمليه مش قويه وكان لازم اتحداها بس
اكتشفت ان ده القرار الصح اللي كان لازم
اعمله من زمان عشان نفسي وعشان
صحتي انت كمان لو هتغيري حاجه فيكي هيبقى
عشان نفسك وعشان صحتك عشان انت عايزه كده
خصوصا ولا شك ان المضيقات اللي بنتعرض لها
في الش هتفضل
بس دي كلها اختبارات لقوتنا وقدرتنا على
المواجهه انا عملت العمليه وبتغير يا ترى
انتم كمان
هتغيروا